we all know that annoying tickle in the
throat
that means only one thing Yoriko can
cough it out wouldn't it be great if
nobody caught into the open air
spreading germs and mucus in all
directions especially when you're around
sometimes I wish we didn't cough at all
how much better would a cough free life
be for all of us or would it turn out to
be deadly this is what if and here's
what would happen if you never coughed a
cough is a reflex that humans and many
animals have this noisy explosion is
coming from deep within your lungs isn't
something you can easily control but for
this hypothetical scenario you'll have
to ignore your reflexes and take York
off into your own hands how would this
play out
let's see your cough doesn't start in
your lungs
it begins with you breathing in and
drawing air into them then your glottis
snaps shut and puts a lid over your
trachea the muscles of your chest cage
abdomen and diaphragm undergo a forceful
contraction normally they push air out
of your nose and mouth but because the
glottis is closed a tremendous pressure
keeps building up in the air passages
when the glottis opens up again the air
rushes through it very quickly in a
strong cough that air can travel at
speeds close to the speed of sound and
that's what makes that barking noise
come out of your chest in a cough free
world your glottis wouldn't shut and the
air wouldn't get stuck in your lungs and
trachea and you wouldn't make any
barking noises
it sounds like an easy fix right not so
fast
coughing happens for a reason it keeps
our throats and Airways free of
irritants when foreign particles like
dirt and dust get into your lungs late
irritate your Airways that in turn
stimulates nerves to send a message to
your brain and that message says
something like and that's how your body
gets rid of the stuff it doesn't need
that includes dust dirt mucus and also
bacteria if you never caught you
wouldn't be spreading germs and diseases
to other people but you would be
infecting yourself because coughing can
be an indication of sickness you might
not even know that you were sick there
would be more cases of lung infections
and more cases of respiratory failure
and some of them wouldn't end up well
in a world where nobody cops you'd have
to practice social isolation to avoid
inhaling any irritants that could make
their way to your lungs and it wouldn't
only last a month or two that isolation
would be for life or you could wear a
hazmat suit everywhere you go a cough
free world would be a very lonely world
global isolation would cause anxiety and
depression anxiety and depression would
trigger a lack of productivity and the
lack of productivity would make global
economies collapse it seems
counterintuitive but coughing is good
for you one study shows that a healthy
person coughs about 11 times in one day
coughing is so important to your
survival that the medical community has
developed the assist cough techniques to
help people get the mucus out of their
lungs when they can't do it on their own
luckily coughing is an involuntary
reflex just like blinking you can't turn
it on and off whenever you want but you
can at least cover your mouth and nose
with a tissue when you cough or coughing
- your elbow just don't cough into the
open air and yes certainly don't COFF on
other people and remember to wash your
hands with soap because if you don't
well that's a story for another what if
[Music]